which part of the screenwriting process
is most difficult for you
i would say the first draft is the most
difficult
looking at the blank page you know
actually the the tree i always write a
treatment before
i write a script and i know that sounds
really
elementary but there are people i know
who don't really do that they just want
to start writing and see what happens
i'm like what's going on you're going to
have an unfinished script
you know you're going to get into the
third of the way through and realize you
don't have an ending a middle or an
ending and you wasted your time
i mean i've highly highly highly
recommend
writing a whole thing out as a treatment
and make sure it works and make sure
it's a feature-length piece too
i mean for me treatments are always
one page of treatment kind of equals
like 10 pages of script
that's how my treatments have always
worked out so if i have a
you know if my treatment is at least
seven or eight pages or nine pages or
something you know you
you probably don't have a whole movie
there but writing the first draft's
always the hardest and just for me the
reason it is is because i want to get
everything right the first time
i don't want to do another draft i want
to get every dot
you know dot the eyes and cross the t's
and have the perfect adjectives picked
out and the perfect
cadence and you know this kind of stuff
so
i will kind of agonize over that and
sometimes you need to almost just be
like you know what
like if you come to a scene that isn't
working that well just
almost like drop in a i say hate to say
it but like a space like a
space saver or something you know kind
of like a little uh block and then go to
the next scene
if you can because then you can come
back to that later
you know and and be more inspired maybe
you'll be more inspired the next day
but just keep moving through it you know
and i always write a certain number of
pages per day no matter what
that's another discipline thing i kind
of picked up like after moving here
was because i had this nice write
scripts very quickly
i had to like deliver scripts within a
few weeks or a month or whatever it was
so i could i got a discipline from that
um but but that first draft is always
the hardest yeah
so much easier to rewrite than to write
you know
are you able to write at home or do you
have to go somewhere i
i couldn't i have to write at home even
if there's construction going on around
and there's like whatever noise
i've written so many scripts under like
bad
noisy circumstances uh
unfortunately because i
have to be at home and i have to be in
my environment like i'm not one of those
people who can go in a coffee shop and
write
i don't know how people do that with all
the noise and
kind of commotion and frankly other
people with laptops and stuff all around
you are probably also writing scripts
it's just kind of you know that those
type of environments don't work for me
so i've always written like i couldn't
even i tried to write a script one time
at a friend's house i was house sitting
and i couldn't do it i
left i called another friend up and i
said can you house it for this time
because i can't stand it i have to go
home and be in my place and write this
my script i can't write it here in his
place so yeah so
everything i've ever written has been at
home yeah
so was that something you always did was
do the space saver
yeah i've done that more lately it kind
of depends on the script
like sometimes if it's a script
especially if it's a script you're
writing for someone else
like i was writing i got this job to
write a script
about like a mummy movie for this guy
one time
and it was like a mummy on a it was
called we were calling it mummy on
campus for a while but that
anyway that wasn't the end of the title
we ended up with but it was a mummy film
on a
college campus and there were some
scenes where i was like yeah i know
exactly what i want to do with that
you know i'm going through the treatment
and then there'd be like a part would be
like you know what i just don't feel
like writing that right now you know
like some attack some action scene or
some kind of complicated sequence it was
my fault because i came up with it
anyway
but i would just skip over to the next
scene and then i'd come back to that one
so you know everybody has their own way
of
their own writing technique i guess and
so i'll do that sometimes
it depends um
and so then could you work that out
later like you know what you're waking
up and you're like i just figured out
the
best way to like have the money money be
in the campus square or
a placeholder yeah you put a placeholder
there or it might or it might be for me
sometimes i don't have a hard time
writing action
i'm not a big fan of writing dialogue
that's something i don't like and the
directors who i'm a big fan of are not
dialogue oriented directors
uh like walter hill is one of my
favorites and you know he's
always got short real short lines
characters don't
yak a lot in his movies so sometimes
they'll come to a certain scene like it
could be a big dialogue scene or
something and i'll be like you know what
depends on where you're at in the day
but i'm like i think i'll come back to
that tomorrow
or you'll just write some dialogue and
then you'll come back to and rewrite
polish it
you know so i mean to me a first draft
is always like there's a bunch of
polishing that goes on in that draft
it's not just a first draft like oh here
it is done and i
just fell right off the table and here
it is you know it's there's always a
certain amount of polishing that
that you do you know and it kind of
depends on whether you're writing it for
yourself
or if you're writing for someone else
because sometimes when you're writing
for
a producer or some company you know
that they're going to make a lot of
changes to it anyway and you've been
having meetings and you've seen that
stuff happening
so that sort of plays into your
decisions sometimes too
um to you know how you approach it
you know the guy that saw you in the
horror shirts that was picking up
the trash at the uh on on by the craft
services or whatever
was that your that was your first
rewrite or sort of yeah
it was my first rewrite because he had
the script i still remember what was
called was called queen of angels
and it was it was a i think it was a
ghost movie
in a hospital like in a haunted hospital
and he even knew where he wanted to film
it
there's a hospital called linda vista
hospital that's like been a location for
many years for
all kinds of movies and i think we might
have filmed there from that
show i can't remember but anyway that's
what it was and he can and
you know i just i don't remember though
the details of what i did on it
like i think i don't remember what he
wanted me to do with it you know what i
mean because it wasn't like it was
unfinished i mean it was a completed
script
i think he just wanted me to maybe like
make it scarier i've had people tell me
that before make it scarier
okay different people think different
things are scary
so that's true so you kind of like
you go through the initial read with it
yeah yeah would i would read it i think
on that one i read it and then i
maybe there were certain scenes he
wanted me to like pump up a bit like the
horror scenes maybe he wasn't that
comfortable with the horror scenes
um jeez you know i
i don't remember now but it was
you know but he did have a finished
script which
the i've had other jobs where people
call me up
i had one gig where a guy called me up
to write
to finish his script and not only finish
it but right around
scenes he had already shot for the movie
so he had like a script
some of those scenes are in the script
that already been filmed like years ago
and i was supposed to write the rest of
it like kind of like the i guess for a
better lack of a better term he
had the beginning and i had to write the
middle in the ending so i did it
um but that was weird because not only
did i have to match his
first act let's say i also had to match
clips that were shot like in you know
with these different actresses
that were already existing footage which
you know for me i was thinking myself or
how are you going to match that footage
in terms of the shooting then you start
thinking about the technical end of it
in the production and
but i was like whatever so i wrote that
i was just wondering how valuable that
one experience where
you meet this guy in the most unlikely
situation that's your first
job in a sense which is so cool and
maybe
because it was a relaxed thing like that
it actually helped you more than if it
was like
well yeah come on in and then you feel
this immense pressure
oh yeah no it was done very casually
literally he was he was
literally picking up the trash while he
was asking me to do it
and i remember that and um you know
i mean i just thought that was very
flattering and i couldn't believe it
you know i thought i was the luckiest
luckiest guy in the world
you know to get to do that and it was i
was nervous when we went over to neo
went over to their offices because i was
like wow i'm in offices of these
you know this established film company
because he knew those
those guys he knew the producers over
there and probably he was trying to push
the
queen of angels on them um
but yeah it was it was cool that it was
done so casually and
and the subsequent some of the
subsequent jobs i did too were all so
casual and
they were very kind of off the cuff like
you know just
like this guy at this effect shop saying
hey i've got some guys looking for a
script
and do you have anything and i'm like
yeah i've got this horror action script
you know that i wrote on spec that i had
i planned on making in virginia beach
which
did not happen but i had it and they
optioned it from me
you know and that was once again done in
a very casual laid back i think i met
with him in like a starbucks or
something and
you know drew up a short form agreement
so i was just wondering how like some
people might pass over certain
opportunities because they're not
it's not like this huge like hollywood
you what you envision
but how that actually groomed you to
then i mean
you took those opportunities you saw
them maybe yeah as like okay i'll do it
and then yeah
it's all about you know a lot of this
this business is built on give and take
and you know
sort of you know people doing favors for
each other and helping each other out in
different points in time
and i had done work talking about the
option job i had done work for that
effect
shop i i knew them from
that background they helped me out with
effects people i needed for my
stuff that i was directing i ended up
they helped me out with that with the
option thing then later on they had a
script that they
i did like a little rewrite on so it's
always this kind of you know we're
we're just hanging out i mean this is
this did not feel like business
you know it was but it wasn't you know
it felt more
and i would and i wasn't remotely
thinking about all this stuff is is too
i'm too good for this stuff i never
thought that i thought it was cool and
fun and you know i was having fun
frankly
so you know and i was learning a lot too
sometimes without even realizing it
every every job you get you learn from
every script you write every movie you
produce or direct or
whether you instigate it and bring it up
from the ground up or you get brought in
on it i mean you learn on
every single one you know maybe that was
it what you just said
like you didn't think you were too good
for and maybe just seeing that
opportunity
i seems like yeah everybody does that
there's move there's definitely movies
i've directed
like and so you know i'll tell you
something there were people
when i first started directing very low
budget micro budget movies who made fun
and they were friends of mine
who were my age who were starting trying
to get in as well and they were
they would make fun of me they would
make fun of my everything about what i
was doing they make fun of the films i
was directing they make fun of the
producer on those they make fun of
everything
guess what they're not directing they
didn't direct anything and they never
did
they just made fun of me and tried to
denigrate what i was doing
and i some of those people i just cut
them loose to be honest with you that
was one of my first like things i kind
of learned out here was like
not only how to build relationships but
also how to get rid of negative
dead weight sometimes too and
you know there's a lot of people that
will scoff at things or say i would
never do that it's like yeah
don't worry you won't you know
you know like i had a guy used to say i
would never do a movie for so-and-so and
say yeah you won't because he's not
going to ask you to
you know i mean it's easy to say what
you won't do
but i don't know yeah i'm not big on
turning things down
you know there's a few movies i've
directed that i'm not very happy with or
whatever but
you know overall for me it's hard to
take those pieces out of the puzzle
because everything leads
to you know each project sort of leads
to the next one
it's it would be very very hard for me
to just
take them all apart and you know
separate all my work to separate all my
credits or all my
off my resume because there's a line
that kind of goes through all of it do
you know what i'm saying
usually one thing leads to another
usually one job does lead to another
and sometimes you have to self-start and
create your own job
create your own opportunity that too
but yeah sitting around saying i'm too
good for that i'm not going to do that
and
that's not going to get you anywhere
right yes
it's interesting how all that kind of
just then led you know and
and some people would have said oh this
guy yeah i'm not gonna you know oh yeah
i had friends from film school who moved
out here who would make fun of
uh you know literally make fun of things
that people i was working with and make
fun of stuff and i was kind of like you
know what it's
it's okay just go do whatever you're
doing and
you know um it's all right you know you
don't have to do it you know you don't
have to be on this project
you know um it's
i don't know i mean people have snobbism
about them you know
and um i haven't seen that getting
anybody anywhere though
and all the people the directors i know
who are like working for
years and making things and however
they're making them
whatever they're they're all
self-starters and they're not snobs and
they're not
they're all hard workers and they all
love what they do
and they've all taken a lot of abuse
or grief or had a lot of difficulties
over the years
but they still do it so you know i think
you kind of make a decision early on in
this
business is you're going to continue
with it or not because you if you don't
want to
do this you know if you don't want to
take these lumps then just get out of it
because there's a lot easier things you
could be doing when we're profitable
you know a lot easier things you could
be doing with your your life
you know but i don't feel like i chose
it i feel like it chose me
you know i i do i mean
so and some people are like i had no
idea if there was anything else i wanted
to do
this was interesting but yeah you know
i don't yeah i can't think of anything
else i'd rather be doing
i mean i i love writing you know i i
sometimes that's my
you know but that's all bound up in the
film too so you know i do
journalism things here and there but you
know what i mean it's it's still all
connected
so
you